time and time again
the black tusk have been hindering the
strategic homeland divisions attempts
at regaining control of the nation's
capital so it's finally time to remove
the btsu leader from the equation
but why did he suddenly have a bunch of
ex-division agents working with him
and what was with that bloody hunter
that kept smacking me in the back of the
head while my back was turned
[Music]
barden schaefer is the leader of the
black tusk specialist unit
the btsu he comes from a family with a
proud
traditional and long line of military
service
and at the age of 19 dropped out of
college and enlisted in the army
there he took no time at all and showing
an exceptionally high degree of skill
which resulted in a swift and steady
rise through the ranks
baden served multiple tours of iraq and
afghanistan
he quickly became known for his highly
tactical way of assessing situations
and having the ability to eliminate
targets with extreme efficiency
later he was assigned to a special
forces unit where he was involved in a
number of dark ops
before eventually being approached by
the black tusk
highly respected among his colleagues it
wasn't long before he was given the role
of specialist unit leader he was given
the task of gaining control of
washington dc
so his employers could establish a new
government
baden legitimately believes he is a true
patriot and that everything he's doing
is for the betterment of the country the
division only answers to the president
but now that he has joined with the btsu
they no longer listen to him
so they're traitors in his eyes
the existing government is corrupt and
the division are nothing more than a
rogue agency
after the division discovered agent lao
and coswold had teamed up with baden
they realized that his threat level was
only increasing regardless of how many
of his ops that they were putting a stop
to
they needed to target the man himself
but barden had been busy
and was recruiting other division agents
too ones who had had a change of heart
and had turned their back on the shd
some of these rogues included shade
wraith
dusk and belfry
mali yarrow codenamed shade was a parole
officer in new york city
and a large number of the people she
dealt with were released from rikers
island
after she was activated as part of the
second wave in new york city
she became aware of the horrific event
that was about to unfold
when the call was made to abandon the
prisoners and leave them to starve
she knew these people and what they were
capable of achieving just because they
are prisoners
they shouldn't be left to slowly die it
would be kinder just to shoot them
she had witnessed these people do great
things after their time incarcerated
some of them were good people that had
simply found themselves in the wrong
situations
some had been locked up for reasonably
minor offences and were only
serving a term of 12 months or less and
some of them hadn't even been convicted
yet
often these were the people who couldn't
afford bail who were awaiting trial
not long after james dragoff the
division agent who'd killed the warden
on rikers island
and then freed the prisoners approached
her
he asked for her assistance in
supporting his family of rikers
she obliged and began working alongside
him in turn
marking her as a rogue agent prior to
joining dragoff she had worked closely
with feylau
and after dragoff's death they
introduced her to barden schaefer
you'll get the delivery tomorrow thanks
shafer you'll get that destabilization
you're looking for
that's not the goal shade we'll keep the
division busy
so you can do whatever high-level
espionage it is you need to do
if you're so smart why the hell are you
running with the rikers you want to be
on the winning side right i want to be
on the right side
okay sure not overly convinced by
baden's claims that he was fighting for
the side that was right
she agreed to support him in exchange
for supplies that iraq is desperately
needed
however gossip quickly started to spread
through the riker ranks
about how she was working with baden
schaefer
delivery tomorrow get a recovery team
together we get coordinates we're just
hoping for some [ __ ] to fall out of the
sky
we'll get them an hour before the drop
safer that way [ __ ]
i was joking i heard you talking to
schaefer you forget that name
okay stop playing you know what happens
to people who play with me
sorry boss not today
sueko tanagi codenamed wraith was a
logistics officer
in the u.s army after she left the armed
forces
she returned home to atlanta and found a
job in her field of expertise
and started working as a logistics
officer for a large transportation
company
later on she was recruited by the
division and using the skills of her
trade
she was activated to help keep sarah's
supply lines operational
at a crucial point where the global
economy was starting to collapse
however at the same time she was
approached by the black tusk
she decided that this was the perfect
opportunity and went on to exploit and
control supply to both the us government
and the global corporation that is
behind the black tusk
wraith is an opportunist and has no
problem working both sides
in order to benefit herself she is
arrogant
narcissistic and gutsy enough to exploit
two of the largest
most powerful organizations around
she is all about working the system
whether it be corporations
or people and when it comes to the
hyenas
they are weak-minded substance abusers
constantly trying to get their next fix
and she's the one capable of fulfilling
this need
in turn making them her puppets
she is very good at getting what she
wants
not long after going rogue her and baden
made contact barden knew that wraith and
the hyenas would become a valuable asset
in the days to come
so he was eager to win her over in order
for her to assist in the operation
lynette edwards codenamed dusk was a
third generation marine
she had chosen to follow in her family's
tradition and pursue a military career
however it was her father that put in a
recommendation to the shd
she was recruited shortly after her
first tour of duty
dusk was activated in washington dc but
it didn't take long for her to come to
the conclusion that the institution
was corrupt in fact she was finding
herself more and more aligned with the
true son's way of thinking
than the shd seeing all the tragedy
caused by the virus
and how overwhelmed the jtf had become
dusk started losing faith in the
division's ability to save washington dc
she quickly came to the conclusion that
more drastic actions needed to be taken
to ensure their survival as a strong
believer in the need for proper
authority and discipline
in her eyes the true sons were the only
ones with the realistic
and viable solution to the situation
she eventually decided that enough was
enough she turned rogue
and joined up with the true sons
when the true sons leader antoine
ridgeway was eventually hunted down
and killed by the division dusk went on
to continue ridgeway's work
with a group of true sons who were
devoted to his cause
dusk is loyal patriotic and cares
greatly for her comrades
unfortunately the attacks had left them
weakened and short on supplies
we need anything running low on rations
bullets
grenades and men so just everything
pretty much
how long can we hold out on the current
stockpile a week
maybe more if we stop feeding the
privates i'll start eating rats before
we stop
feeding our men that's how you get a
mutiny
she would do whatever it took to help a
new family even if it meant making a
deal with the devil
dusk would use a contacts to gain a
connection within the black tusk
and offer a trade in return for food
water and weapons
skylar williams code name belfry served
in the u.s army
and was eventually approached by the shd
and recruited as an agent
after retiring from the army he went on
to become a local police officer
in a predominantly residential commuter
town
following the outbreak he was activated
in his home state of maryland
but was stationed at the washington dc
sarah camp in dz south
but unfortunately it was his experience
in these camps
that would change his allegiance
he witnessed the insufficiently tested
chemical called dc62
being pushed into these camps by the
people who were supposed to be
protecting them
watch countless families succumb to this
lethal yellow powder
gasping for air clawing frantically at
their throats
while the toxic fumes burn their lungs
causing asphyxiation
and ultimately their death
questioning his role as a division agent
feeling partially responsible
and equally helpless at the same time he
left his post
in turn being flagged as rogue
eventually he made contact with baden
where he would offer his assistance
in exchange for supplies he was working
to help other victims of these
quarantine camps
the outcasts
congratulations lao you just got a new
assignment
sniper duty no bts you
you're no assassin what you want to be a
sniper now
pretty sure you need depth perception
for that gig wouldn't work even if you
had a robo-eye
i've seen you in the field you like
getting your hands dirty
no i don't but i'm not afraid to do
what's necessary
you ready to work directly for the
president for your country
honey what's funny you just promoted me
to my old job
the division was activated by the
president but as soon as they went
against him and your ai forgot to update
the line of succession
you stopped working for the president
the way i see it
you and the rogues we've recruited are
the only agents still on mission
but that doesn't mean i have to like it
or you
barton made it official by giving faye a
position within the btsu ranks
her first job to guard president ellis
but this is where things started to
become a little more difficult than he'd
expected
the rogue agents they had introduced to
baden when exactly what you'd call
low maintenance bringing them on board
came at a considerable cost
and they were proving to be somewhat
challenging to work with
you made the deadline i'm a man of my
word for now
i need another delivery you know you're
not my only operator
i know but i'm your best
and if you want to keep me happy you'll
find a way to get a delivery of tear gas
to
judiciary square the sooner the better
whatever you need wraith i aim to please
that's my good boy i knew you wouldn't
let me down
get a crew together supply or combat
supply
got a new contact needs to prove himself
oh [ __ ]
we getting helicopter drones no i didn't
ask for anything that bad [ __ ]
too bad i could do some real damage with
one of those yeah
pretty sure you just get high and blow
up another safe house
button obliged wraith's request he knew
she had
substantial influence over the hyenas
and he needed them
they had a part to play in the upcoming
op unfortunately
wraith knew this and had no problem
testing how far she could push things
to get what she wanted
what can i do for you now you can get
that tone out of your voice
what can i do for you wraith you got an
eta on my delivery
should have everything ready for your
deadline tomorrow good boy
are you sure you don't need anything
else just the tear gas
when you said you were going to test me
i expected a test
you're still being tested you haven't
made the delivery yet
i value punctuality i'm always on time
we'll see dusk contacted baden
and explained the situation that her and
the true sons were in
supplies were critically low and they
didn't have enough weapons to go around
barton agreed to the request of
assistance and made a deal where they
would work together
need an emergency supply drop what kind
weapons or rations
yes air drop or do you need a delivery
whatever gets my men
fed and armed by tomorrow you got enough
ammo to take on hostiles one and two
squads then it gets dicey
i can arrange an airdrop and send
coordinates have your team there
in two hours thanks shafer no problem
dusk
shafer how can i help you dusk want to
let you know we got the supply drive
glad to hear it my boys are fed and
armed and ready to fight
glad to hear it what do you need wanted
to set up a meet
what for i like to know who i'm working
with i always find a face to face tells
you so much more than a voice on the
radio
fair enough whenever you're free come
meet me in southwest i've got a safe
house there
looking forward to meeting you sounds
good looking forward to meeting you too
dusk
however this was all getting a bit much
his budget was being strained
and resources stretched then baden
started questioning whether these rogue
agents were even worth all of this
hassle
and if they could even be trusted he
contacted faye to discuss his concerns
faye this is schaefer i'm worried this
up is getting a little expensive
are we sure we want to spend all these
resources on the hyenas and the true
suns
dusk wants to meet up in person now
either she's got a crush on me
or this is a trap how well do you really
know these people we're working with
unable to get hold of faye he decided to
take a step back and assess the
situation
while dealing with other pressing
matters but it was during this time that
the rogue agents started to feel
neglected
went to the mate but you weren't there
what happened sorry
i had to handle something in dc you're
the one who wanted to meet
and you stand me up i didn't mean to
disrespect you
i should have called but these comms
aren't the most secure and i didn't want
to give away your location
that's okay shafer this time you come to
me
it's too much of a pain in the ass for
me to get off the island
name the time and place i'll be there
once you land in two bridges ping me and
alison
what is it belfry you working with
schaefer yeah you know i am
what do you think of them oh very
professional you've been getting your
deliveries yeah
on time and in full [ __ ] you're not
no oh guess he likes me better than you
dusk what is it belfry what do you think
of schaefer
you like working with him he's my [ __ ]
what's not to like
you getting your deliveries yeah he
saved my ass
last week with a ration supply drop [ __ ]
he blowing you off he's not responding
to my calls
maybe he realized your crazy ass was a
lost cause and cut his losses
thanks dusk hope he cuts you too
schaefer this is belfree come in what
can i do for you
we're running low on munitions
incendiaries and rations we need a
delivery yesterday
i can get an airdrop put together for
you in two hours have something to take
care of first
just need a drop zone west end i have a
recovery team based there perfect
i'll put it together hold tight the
supply drop will be there
soon don't leave me hanging again i
wouldn't do that
you can trust me and as every parent
knows
when the kids feel neglected they start
to play up
i don't know if you're new to this whole
comms thing
but you should really be using code
or get us more secure channels i've
gotta work with the tools at my disposal
wraith seems a bit reckless makes me
worry about you schaefer
sweet of you to worry you're sloppy
either you're trying to get yourself
or me killed and if you're trying to get
me killed i hate to disappoint you
but better men have tried and failed
wraith
i'm not suicidal and i know that your
position with the hyenas allows us to
operate more freely in dc
i see your value i am not sloppy
but resources are limited and we all
have to make do
with what we have well done
you didn't yell at me you had a
reasonable answer for your way of
working
and complimented me well then
you passed the test
baden is a patient man who had no
problem staying composed
as he has dealt with many challenging
situations in his career but he was
starting to doubt whether he could work
with these people
unable to get in contact with faye he
talks to someone by the name of natalia
sokolova
natalia i'm not sure about this they
wanted black tusk to collaborate with
the government
this is space chance to prove her agents
are worthy
and our chance to keep my business
partners happy i think the only thing
she's proving is a division really
needed a better screening process
you brought her in her failures are
yours
fix it i do not tolerate failure
i understand it isn't clear who natalya
is to barden
but she's certainly the one calling the
shots she could be someone further at
the chain within the black tusk
or maybe even the main contact for the
organization that has employed them
biden instructed shade to wreak havoc on
the division in new york city
she set to work attacking multiple sites
in the financial district
civic center and two bridges while
wraith focused on the northeastern side
of dc
including downtown west downtown east
federal triangle
and judiciary square dusk made moves
in southeastern dc capturing multiple
sites of value
in east mall southwest and capitol hill
and belfry directed his efforts towards
the west side of dc
including the districts of constitution
hall foggy bottom
and west end but also new york's coney
island
one by one the division was able to
locate the rogue agents in lower
manhattan and dc
although they put up a strong fight the
division agents were quickly able to
take them down
but this did include the assistance from
an unlikely foe
in each instance when finally able to
detect the location of the rogue agents
a hunter would appear interestingly
he didn't seem to be focused solely on
the division agents he was hostile to
both sides of the conflict
regardless having eliminated his rogue
agents barton schaefer eventually made
his location known
he was on coney island division agents
had to navigate their way through the
amusement park
which was riddled with rikers yet a
familiar face kept making an appearance
the hunter the agents have met time and
time again while disposing of baden's
rogues
was also there and this hunter was
taking down rikers
faster than the agents were able to
progress through the park whenever they
would get close
he would vanish over the comms
barton could be heard telling the hunter
to quit playing around and kill the
agents
and this is where the division met face
to face with the hunter that had been
following them throughout this operation
after a long dare i said couple of
attempts even the agents managed to take
down the hunter
barton updated natalya circle over she
inquired of the hunter asset
and when biden informed her that he'd
been eliminated she ordered him to clean
up his mess and finish the job
budden instructed his group of elite
btsu operators to assemble
and prepare for the fast approaching
division agents
but the agents made short work of them
and within no time at all
baden's guards were quickly disposed of
in a final offensive push barton took
the fight to the agents
and although he was strong and put up a
formidable resistance they eventually
managed to take him down
biden was critically injured but not
killed
a halo was sent in to retrieve him where
he would be brought back to health
and then questioned on his knowledge
around the black tusk and the
organization who had employed them
okay so this whole manhunt obviously
leads to a hell of a lot more questions
like every manhunt to be fair for
example who is natalya circle over
and what is a relation to the black task
does this operation confirm that the
hunters are working with the btsu
or maybe due to the circle over name
they have something to do with the
russians
but i think this video has gone on for
long enough that can of worms could have
me babbling on for another 20-30 minutes
maybe i should put together another
speculation video on these questions
it's been a while since i made one of
those anyway what do you think
does this confirm the hunter's
intentions do you think that this is the
first sign
that the russians are using this
opportunity to seize control of the
united states
let me know in the comments otherwise i
hope you've enjoyed this video and i'll
catch you in the next one
[Music]
cheers
[Music]
laughs